welcome back to cbs this morning
as lawmakers debate a new coronavirus
relief package
many wanted to include another round of
1200 dollar stimulus payments to many
americans
in the first round nearly 1.4 billion
dollars went to people
who are dead the irs now says spouses
and others who receive those payments
should return the money but as consumer
investigative correspondent anna warner
found out
some people cannot get the money they're
entitled to anna what is going on
yeah good morning jerica it might sound
logical that if someone gets a check
from the government
that check was meant to be cashed but we
found that's not necessarily the case
leaving some people in a bind it's been
a tough couple of years
earlier this year ian davis lost his
wife sirona
a 32 year old mom and singer she died in
surgery related to kidney problems in
february
[Music]
i miss everything about her not a day
not a moment goes by that i don't think
about her
her laugh her joy for life
now davis who had been caring for his
wife full-time is struggling to find
work he's staying with family along with
his five-year-old son
in may he thought he'd caught a break
when a joint stimulus check for 2400
arrived for him and sirona but when he
went to the bank
what did they say to you can't do
anything because even with a death
certificate
they said they couldn't do anything to
cash it jenny rabiac faced a similar
problem
her husband died march 21st possibly of
covid19
she also got this joint check for
herself and her husband
that she too had trouble cashing at the
bank
we're going to freeze your husband your
late husband's 1200
because he deceased nobody knew what to
do and they still don't know what to do
why the confusion jay mctigue oversees
irs
audits at the government accountability
office and says when the stimulus checks
first went out
irs council made the initial legal
determination
that you know they could not stop
payments to deceased individuals
in its probe into the handling of the
cares act mctonic's agency found
because of the way the law was written
anyone who filed a tax return in 2018 or
2019 was in fact entitled to that
stimulus money
even if they were deceased at the time
of payment
so they initially said their own people
said that you can't
hold up this money to these people even
though they're passed away
that's our understanding so the irs sent
out some 1.1 million
payments to deceased individuals some of
them like this one
even had the letters decd for deceased
on them then as word got out on
april 17 reporters asked president trump
what should happen to money
sent to dead people we'll get that back
everything we're going to get back
a few weeks later on may 6 the irs
changed course saying on its website if
payments went to someone who was dead
the money should be sent back so
initially they made one determination
then midstream they flipped
that's correct and with he and his
wife's names on a single check for
twenty four hundred dollars
ian davis couldn't even cash it to get
his own twelve hundred
and that just didn't make any sense to
me yeah it just kind of puts uh people
like me in limbo and i don't think that
that's fair
to people loved ones this year
that's why people are in such a muddle
they don't know what to do
nina olson is executive director of the
non-profit center for taxpayer rights
i am hearing more from people who
are they're stuck because they have a
check
in both names or they have a check in a
decedent name
and so the banks will not let them cash
the check
mctige says people who are entitled to
the money might get an adjustment but
only on
next year's tax return so they won't get
this money until next year
that's my understanding which seems to
run counter to the intention of why they
sent this money out in the first place
one could make that argument meaning
davis may wait another year for his
money
how helpful would that be for you right
now oh it would be extremely helpful
it all comes down to money
so jenny rabiac eventually got her bank
to free up her money but she's not sure
if the irs might take some of it back
next year when taxes get filed the irs
did not respond to our specific
questions about this
issue but in a general statement it said
it responded with
unprecedented speed to issue stimulus
payments
and that auditors found 98 of payments
were correctly computed in regard to
those uncashed
checks sent to deceased people those
have all
now been canceled gail
boy anna that's very confusing because
first you say you get it if you're
deceased now they're trying to change it
midstream but it
doesn't help when you need the money now
and you can't even get the money that's
rightfully do you that's a very tough
position right
exactly make any sense thank you thank
you very much
anna warner